well the state's five percent positivity  rate also raised eyebrows during today's  covet update  health officials say the 14-day long  stretch is due to backlog and new lab  data  the state is working hard to get  residents test results back quick but  several large labs submitted big test  results this week  nothing unusual just higher volume now a  good reminder why health officials focus  on trends and not  on one day data another concern was a  potential shortage of the johnson  johnson vaccine  that could cause a setback in the  distribution  on the supply of jnj to just remind  everyone that  the the levels of pfizer and moderna  are increasing every week so i do  expect that the j j impact won't have a  severe impact on access  well eight news now was invited today to  the grand opening of the new fire  station 61  in the east side as part of the launch  it was used to distribute 250 of the  johnson johnson vaccines to residents on  a first come  first serve base kirsten